it's great to welcome to the program
today near Al who is the best-selling
author of hooked how to build
habit-forming products and in
distractible how to control your
attention and choose your life it's so
great to have you on I appreciate your
time my pleasure thanks for having me
so one of the things I find really
interesting about your take on addictive
technology social media distraction low
attention span culture is that on a lot
of the basis of what is causing this you
seem to agree with lots of the other
people that that write on this but where
you seem to push back is the idea that
the human mind is sort of defenseless
that we are sort of just more victims
than we are less victims than maybe some
others believe when it comes to this
addiction and distractibility give us
maybe to start just like a general sense
of your approach to the technologies
that our effort very often called the
culprits right now and how we should
sort of relate to them or think about
them yeah I think it's a really
convenient excuse I think we love to
blame others and say oh I can't do
anything about it right what am I going
to do so I think what we see today is
that we have a big camp of people who
are what we call the blamers the blamers
when it comes to distraction you said
they say you see Facebook is doing it to
me my iPhone is doing it to me somebody
else is doing it to me and then you have
the shamers the shame er this is what I
used to do they shame themselves they
say oh I must be deficient maybe I'm
lazy maybe I am not cut out for this job
you see maybe I have a short attention
span
they they they shame themselves which of
course makes the problem even worse
because when you feel bad you look for a
distraction to take your mind off of why
you feel bad so the right way to be is
not to be a blame ER or a shame er I
think the right approach is to be what
we call a claim er a claim er
acknowledges that this isn't your fault
right you didn't invent the iPhone you
didn't invent email you didn't invent
Facebook it's not your fault
but guess what it's your responsibility
and by claiming responsibility we fend
off what's called learned helplessness
so a lot of tech critics say your brain
is being hijacked it's addicting you
it's doing it to you and by believing
that rubbish not only is it not
scientifically true
but it actually leads to people
believing it is true so that they don't
do anything about the problem ironically
making the problem even worse so let's
break down a few of the things you said
there one is that the questioning the
notion that that it's objectively true I
mean the the I want to dig into that a
little bit because I'm guessing you
would grant that the sort of variable
rewards system of something like
scrolling Facebook does something
different in the brain than like having
a novel sitting near your desk when
you're working like that there is
something different about that would you
concede at least that much is it
different of course but that doesn't
mean that just because something is a
variable reward that it's hijacking your
brain or very much remember by the way
people said the exact same things
verbatim to what they're saying today
about the mind melting power of
Technology about the novel they talked
about how novels were going to in feeble
men's minds and they know women should
never be exposed to novels because they
thought they would become you know
lascivious and all this terrible things
would happen
same exact thing what happened we
adapted that's what happened so that
that's the question i guess which i want
to get to which is you've pointed out
that often times like distraction at
work is less about face book is sitting
there on your desk but maybe more about
the company culture the job that you're
in that there are other things that need
to be considered what about in the
personal life would you make the same
analogy there sure that in fact what I
found in my five years of research is
that the reason we get distracted is not
just because of the external triggers of
course the pings and dings and rings
play a role but in fact if you look at
where we are most likely to get
distracted the root cause of distraction
is not the external triggers it's the
internal triggers its feeling this
uncomfortable emotional state that we
want to escape from when we're feeling
lonely we check Facebook when we're
uncertain we Google when we're bored we
check ESPN we check the news we check
Pinterest reddit all of these products
and services cater to these
uncomfortable emotional triggers so that
is the Achilles heel I'm telling you as
an industry insider these techniques are
good they're not that good
right they're not mind-controlling
they're not hijacking your brain that's
rubbish if you understand why you get
triggered why you are turning to
distraction you can do something about
it so the techniques like hide the
distracting apps five pages deep in your
in your phone for example or put an app
on your phone that only gives you 15
minutes on Instagram a day or something
like that it is that just to piecemeal
and it doesn't really get at the root of
the problem right exactly go gray
scaling your phone or putting the you
know
hiding the triggers yeah that's nice
it's not the root cause of the problem
if you don't understand why you're
getting distracted why are you returning
to these things to take your mind off of
an uncomfortable emotional state and if
you don't recognize that you need to
either fix the source of the problem or
learn tactics to cope with discomfort in
a healthier manner you will always be
distracted by something remember Plato
talked about distraction 2,500 years
before the iPhone this is not a new
problem and if you think honestly if
Facebook suddenly shut down and
Zuckerberg said I have enough money I'm
done do you think tomorrow people would
start reading Shakespeare and Chaucer in
their spare time of course not no we're
distracted by other stuff and so if we
don't understand the root cause of the
problem and address it and learn how to
deal with in a healthier manner we will
always find distraction somewhere so in
the book and distractible you have a
sort of top level but also quite
nitty-gritty ideas and techniques for
people depending on the situation there
and obviously the the nitty-gritty sort
of exceeds the scope of this
conversation but can you tell us a
little bit about what the general
approaches that you recommend yes it's
basically four steps to becoming in
distractible the first step is to master
those internal triggers that we've been
talking about the second step is to make
time for traction so many people myself
included we moan and complain about how
distracted we are and we blame the tech
companies but we don't actually ask
ourselves wait what did I want to do
with my time did you know that
two-thirds of Americans don't keep any
sort of a calendar we we have security
systems on our homes and we have alarms
on our cars and we have our money in
banks where there safeguard its
safeguarded
vault but when it comes to our time sure
come on over steal as much of it as you
want so if you don't plan your day
somebody's gonna plan it for you so the
second step is to make sure that we
understand what is traction and what is
distraction in our life and you cannot
call something a distraction unless you
know what it distracted you from so you
have to plan your time the third step is
to hack back the external triggers turns
out that there are so many technologies
and tools out there most of them
absolutely free that you can use to
screw Facebook to mess with YouTube to
hack back these products in a way that
serves you and guess what there's
nothing they can do about it
you can use Chrome extensions like
Facebook newsfeed Eradicator like
YouTube DF that will scrub all the
distractions out of those products and
make sure that use that they serve you
as opposed to you serving them the
fourth step is to prevent distraction
with pacts and this is about making a
contract some kind of a pre commitment
that helps us stay on track and helps us
form a new identity so this is where I
really am passionate about helping
people have a moniker unnamed they can
call themselves to proudly declare I am
indestructible I'm not the kind of
person who responds to every message
within 30 seconds I don't let my
attention in my life and my and my time
be controlled by others I decide that
for myself I am in distractible one of
the things that I've found useful some
some of the tips have come from from
your work is the idea of grouping your
day as sort of batch processing and
separating the day into sort of sections
so you mentioned the responding to
emails I've talked about you know I put
emails I need to respond to that day in
a today folder and that weekend in this
week folder I think I got that from you
although maybe not I did get okay good
that's right and and the great thing
about it is I'm not I'm taking it out of
my head so it doesn't occupy spaces I
have to remember this thing there's a
system where I'm processing the inputs
and I'm establishing how and when I I
will follow up the problem that I see
with it and I'm curious what you think
about this is that it works really well
with things like work email and it works
quite well with when in the day am i
researching for my show
and preparing for interviews versus
doing more technical stuff or business
stuff but I don't have kids if I had
kids I don't know that the entire system
doesn't get blown up if I was attending
to a different type of job for example
where people show up in my office and I
can't control that I I think that some
of the I feel like a lot of these
systems might fall apart but I want to
hear from you whether they still work
well I'm super glad to hear that it
works for you save this hypothetical if
you have kids let's be happy that it
works for you this email system that I
talked about can help people save up to
90 percent people have told me yeah 90
percent of time they spend on email
diminishes through this amazing practice
of deciding when something needs a reply
and then limiting how many times you
touch each email to only twice a lot
more details in the book we don't have
time to cover right now life-changing
practice believe me it absolutely saves
me so I can't let hours of time spent on
email and it turns out that this
practice of time boxing you know I do
have kids I have I have a little girl
who's 11 years old and these same exact
practices can be adapted for anyone in
any situation I've talked to people who
have many kids who use this this
practice all sorts of different jobs the
idea here is to help you do whatever it
is you think is important I want to help
you live out your values not to tell you
what your values should be so if
physical fitness is important to you is
that on your calendar if spending time
with your kids is important to you have
you made time for it if being an
available friend is important that
should have hold time on your calendar
as well what I think most people do
myself included I used to only make time
for the work stuff and everybody else
would get the scraps right including
myself time for working out time for
sleep time for taking care of myself
whatever whatever was left over is what
I would get and so every day felt like a
hurried mess and I could never
accomplish everything I wanted to
accomplish as opposed to when you become
indestructible you can have this amazing
feeling of finishing your day and saying
wow I did exactly what I said I would do
and nothing more and nothing less one of
the things that I think is important
also is it being okay to schedule in
time for nothing in the sense that
there's a lot of social cultural key
news that busyness is like is deified in
some way and yeah you know all the stuff
and I think people in my audience do too
and it might be training people to
believe that unscheduled time is a
problem or time where you're just kind
of doing whatever is a problem but in
fact it's it's part of what you're
talking about absolutely so the time you
plan to waste is not waste of time I
don't say that you should only plan
productive stuff or work stuff I want
you to plan time for meditation if it's
important to you or prayer if it's
important to you or painting or taking a
walk or staring at the cracks in the
ceiling I don't really care what I want
you to do is to do whatever you yourself
want to do which includes time for
social media time for video games time
to watch Netflix there's nothing wrong
with that stuff and don't let any of
those stupid tech critics tell you that
it's melting your brain that's rubbish
if you plan time for it enjoy it but
don't use it on the app makers schedule
don't use it when Facebook wants you to
use it use it when you plan to use it so
one of the things I wanted to get your
thoughts on is I'm sure you've seen
these articles that float around you
know 20 things you should do before 6:00
a.m. to own the day or this type of
thing is there anything you've come
across that really suggests starting the
day super early is objectively an
advantage to everyone or does it really
just depend on one sort of rhythm flow
and when they work best yes so here's
the thing everything in my book you know
I come from an academic background I
taught at Stanford for many years I've
taught the hey hey so planner Institute
of Design at Stanford so when I write a
book it's not only that it has to work
it has to work for me personally right I
books that I write books that I myself
need I was patient zero here I was the
most distracted people person you would
ever meet and so it was very important
for me that that these techniques work
but that's not good enough
many of the self-help books out there
they tell you you know wake up at 4 a.m.
and take a shower in freezing water why
because it worked for me that's not good
enough everything in my book is backed
by peer-reviewed studies you'll see a 30
page appendix full of peer-reviewed
journals with that these techniques have
been verified and validated by my
academic research and when it comes to
the waking up stuff I mean people can be
distracted or not
tracted productive or unproductive at
any time of day that's right it's it's
not about if look if you like waking up
early and that suits you great do it if
you like to meditate great do it but my
idea here is not to tell you that you
should do those things what I want to
help you do is do what let's face it you
already know what to do right we all
know right we need to stop this
obsession of oh if I only knew the
secret if I only knew the magic answer
you know already you want to get into
shape you know how to get into shape you
want to have a better relationship with
your friends and family be fully present
you want to do better at your job do the
damn work especially the hard stuff that
other people don't want to do the
problem isn't that we don't know what to
do the problem is that we don't know how
to stop getting distracted from doing
the things we know we want to do the
book is called in distractible how to
control your attention and choose your
life we've been speaking with the book's
author NIR Eyal thank you so much for
spending some time with me today and
telling us about the book
my pleasure David thank you